[Applause]
all right thank you my name is Chad
shear so I'm gonna be talking about
lightweight probabilistic programming
and Julia and I'm a senior data
scientist at Metis we teach a 12-week
intensive data science bootcamp and just
starting off I'd like to thank Medus for
giving me about 30% of my time to spend
on projects like this so I had posted
this just a bit ago and this is also on
the on the PI data slack Channel in case
you would like to follow along I know it
can be difficult to see from the back
you can go to this and and this should
hopefully update life just a little bit
about me I was the technical lead for
language language evaluation team for
the DARPA program probabilistic
programming for advancing machine
learning and I have a few workshop
publications along those lines one of
these was before I before I took that
role and the last two were at the very
end when we had some funding to do some
independent development and if you have
the slides these are also links in case
that any of that work is interesting to
you so let's talk about making rational
decisions this is a big motivation for
Bayesian analysis and in turn
probabilistic programming in general so
we want to be able to get to rational
decisions but there's always some
uncertainty involved in our data so we
need to have some way to manage that
uncertainty and a good foundational
framework for managing uncertainty comes
from Bayesian analysis it turns out that
a lot of the mechanics of Bayesian
analysis can be pushed to a compiler and
that's exactly the the idea of
probabilistic programming so we write a
model at a relatively high level the
compiler takes care of a lot of the nuts
and bolts of turning this into code that
then executes to give us the inference
methods so there are a couple of
different places that that are kind of
sweet spots for probabilistic
programming one of them is any case
where you need to really be able to
manage risk uncertainty is a big deal we
it comes in the in the in the form of
risk and in particular medicine finance
and insurance all I'll have that have a
big role in this the second is anytime
you have some kind of custom modeling
that you would like to be able to do so
if you have any kind of a maybe you have
a physical system where you know you
understand how the physics have the
physics behave something in similar in
terms of economics you may also have
hypothesis testing where the the you're
doing a hypothesis test against two
generative approaches and just in
general modeling as a simulation is
something that's really well suited to
to estimation and inference in terms of
probabilistic programming because you've
ever seen any systems in probabilistic
programming these are maybe some of the
some of the better-known systems that
that people use quite a bit Stan over
here is a system that's written in C++
and is you write models in the in the
form of a of a custom standalone
language that are then compiled into C++
the remainder of these except touring
all of them you write either C++ or
typically there's a Python front-end so
here's a PI mc3 is a very popular one
that I've done a lot of work in in terms
of my blog a lot of the the things I
write about are in terms of Pi mt3 PI
Rho is a relatively new development from
uber uber AI Labs this is a
probabilistic torch and the black black
box or black cube is Edward tensorflow
also recently built a tensor flow
probability extension so so you can also
do this actually directly in tensor flow
and then finally touring jail is another
library with pretty similar syntax to
what I'm going to show you just a little
bit different approach in terms of the
backend okay so there are a lot of a lot
of applications of probabilistic
programming first there are
business applications so this is an
example from my blog and in this case
we're trying to model the uncertainty
involving the price elasticity of demand
so when the price of an of an item goes
up the demand goes down but the question
is at what rate so we'd like to assign
that that elasticity some uncertainty
and then observe data and then try to
reason about it in a in a rational way
so the goal here is to try to maximize
the profit and the question is what
price should you set in order to
maximize the expected profit so you can
see for a given price there's really a
distribution which are the the very very
thin black sort of hair lines
corresponding to what may be all
possible worlds of of demand curves and
then for a given price we really have
this distribution of possible profits
that might be realized this model I've
started off as I thought it was going to
be a relatively simple thing but
actually got a lot more involved than I
had expected so it was really
interesting to work with and you can
find some details on that in my blog if
you're interested this is an example of
missing data looking into this a little
bit missing data is you know there are a
lot of mostly sort of ad hoc approaches
that people tend to take with missing
data probabilistic programming it turns
out can just handle it from first
principles and in this case whoops in
this case this is a simple linear model
with a with of course quadratic data
terms the the very thin black line is
the ground truth of course usually that
wouldn't be observed the blue points are
data that were observed for both the x
and the y values but for some of the
data points the orange ones we either
didn't observe the we either didn't
observe the x value or we didn't observe
the Y value so there was some
uncertainty in one or the other or if
you look very closely that you probably
can't see it on the projector but there
are also some very faint orange points
so there's one point that actually was
missing both the X and the y and as it
turns out in PI MC 3 at least a
you have to do absolutely nothing
special to manage this so I just put
this data in and said please give me the
the estimates the posterior estimates
for the parameters and you don't have to
do anything special to manage that
missing data so that's that's very
useful in a lot of applications so if
you've talked to anyone who works in
Julia you've probably heard about the
then talk about the two language problem
this is something that was one of kind
of the driving forces behind development
of the - of the julia language and it's
this idea that in a lot of languages
there's a disconnect between what we
think of as the user language and the
developer language users write one thing
and developers write another thing or at
the very least users think in some terms
developers think in entirely different
terms so for example in Python we want
to write Python users want to write
Python developers would like to write
Python but it doesn't always work that
way right you end up writing C quite a
bit or C++ maybe you're even writing
scythe on or or what's the other number
you're maybe either writing scythe on or
number friendly code which is sort of
almost but not quite Python right so
Python maybe you have to go back and
forth with C if you're working in deep
learning or a lot of the popular
probabilistic programming systems
there's also a deep learning framework
so we call it the two language problem
but maybe it's really a three language
problem in this case this has a few
problems associated with it it's a lot
harder for beginner users to get up to
speed with systems like this where they
have to learn not just one language but
two or possibly three or at least three
different terms to think in as they're
trying to navigate this space it's also
a barrier to entry for developers we'd
like for people to come in and start
using our system and sort of gradually
migrate toward developing the core of
the system and this kind of puts a wall
between the users and their developers
it limits it limits communication makes
communication potentially difficult
between them and and puts a barrier to
that transition
and it also limits extensibility right
if I if I have some system that's built
in terms of a particular deep learning
framework it's potentially a big deal to
try to move over to a different back-end
right so here's a new approach in Julia
the idea is we have this mathematical
code this is you see a lot of models
written this way and the idea is that mu
and Sigma we're going to think of as the
parameters and the X J's are the data
that that we're going to observe
conditional on those parameters right
and then of course Bayes law we observe
the data and we want to go backwards and
make inferences about what those
parameters might have been so let's call
this tilde code or the or the code that
you'll see in a bit when we work in this
in these terms so then a model in this
approach is what we can think of as a
lossless data structure so we should be
able to move seamlessly between the raw
code and the internal representation of
the model we can have combinators to
transform the code before the
compilation so this makes it easy for
for beginners to see okay here's what I
wrote here's what I might have written
here to the kind of the kind of
transformations that might be reasonable
experts can code these things and apply
them to beginners code and then
beginners can start to level up and see
how they might be writing models or how
they might be thinking about things so
this has a few advantages it's
transparent the the code that we're
working in is the same as it were
writing things in the same terms as what
we initially what we initially write so
it's not like there's some magical
compiler that takes our source code and
turns it into something that we we can't
comprehend right it's also composable
because i'm going between tilde code and
tilde code or between model and model I
can chain these things together
arbitrarily so that potentially makes
things very powerful you think is
similar to how we chain together
commands at the unix command line prompt
right and finally its back-end agnostic
so all each of these transformations
leaves us with still model or still
tilde code so I'm not married to a
particular deep learning framework I'm
not married to a particular approach for
the backend so here's a here's a simple
end and there's there's no intrinsic
overhead so in this was the originally
the title of my slide but any time we
are taking a compiler based approach
there's no real intrinsic overhead
beyond what's what's what's dealt by the
intermediate representation right so
here there really is no intermediate
representation it's very it's very
front-end oriented but we can still have
these transformations so this approach
itself has no overhead and really you're
limited only by the models that you
write and the back end which the back
ends are entirely independent right so
if I write it back end and it's really
awful someone else can write a different
back end and it can have any there's no
limitation on performance imposed but
from one back-end to the next so here's
a really simple example of this here's
the model that we looked at just a
minute ago so the theory says if we want
to get the posterior for MU and Sigma
conditional on some data X that's going
to be proportional to the prior
distribution on mu and Sigma times the
likelihood which is just the probability
or the probability density of X given mu
and Sigma
so in sauce the the code that we write
will will look very similar to the
original code that we would write just
in a mathematical formulation and if for
example we apply the know u terms that
no you turn sampler that was popularized
in the Stan probabilistic programming
language we can very easily get to a set
of samples
all right so here are some simple model
combinators we can we can take a model
that's written like this now this is
this is not conditional on anything
right this is just if you sample from
this it will it will find the Mew the
Sigma and the EXO will generate all
three of those but maybe I want to
observe value statically so in some
cases I may want to I may have a
relatively small data set that I'd like
to condition on or maybe my data gives
me some structural information that can
that that I can base optimizations on
from that point of course in most cases
my data is too big to in line so I can
also do this dynamically and I'm sorry
for the glare hopefully you can still
read most of this so if I say M : X X is
then interpreted as a symbol and the
only thing that changes is that it now
becomes an argument in my model okay so
when I compile this to any of the
backends X will then be treated as data
that's given in the input okay
whereas anything that's that hasn't been
seen to this point mu and Sigma in this
case are treated as parameters to to be
inferred okay let's look a little bit at
composability so here's something that
we would like to be able to do we can
write a mixture model where we input X
just some data and some components okay
so the components abstractly we can
think of these as distributions and
maybe I have some weights that usually
in a bayesian context we'd like the
weights to take a darish lay a douche
laid prior okay so you can think of this
just like we're finding a random
probability and then my data just
follows a mixture model with those
components and the given weights and oh
and we have this iid Combinator because
there's not just one value for the X's
but there's however many we give to the
input
well I could have my components be
distributions but in this framework we
can get to a point where we're actually
providing models as inputs
okay so models and distributions should
be interchangeable so if I do this then
of course this is the only change here
is that I've I've given the the
components as a as a line in the
resulting code okay another example that
comes up in the for example in the no
u-turn sampler that we showed saw just a
minute ago is metaprogramming to get to
the log density computation so let's say
have the model like this this is the
same one that we are sort of running
example and this is conditional on some
x value well what I'd like to be able to
get to excuse me is a a computation that
that finds the log density for any given
X input and any given parameters okay so
then I can use this I can fix the data
and sample over the different parameter
values so a program that does this might
look like this first we set the
log-likelihood to zero and then anytime
we see some assignment like this says
I'm going to observe some new values
some Sigma values some x value we have
to set that that has to either come from
the parameters or it has to come from
the data so here we can see mu comes
from the parameters Sigma comes from the
parameters and X comes from the data and
beyond that when we get to any one of
the any one of these variables we just
have to increment the log posterior
density according to the the log PDF of
whatever distribution the value came
from and the observed value well we
didn't have to write this by hand this
is actually created by the compiler so
when we got to this new assignment that
this this block of code is replaced with
this block of code and in fact the
entire model is ripped
placed with the green box on the bottom
and we can see that the the form the
stakes then is just assignment
assignment assignment and in front we
have to initialize the log posterior
density and at the at the very end we
have to return what we've been commented
to that point so this is the code that
does that and I don't expect this
everyone just say oh well of course
that's how you do it but the point is
this is relatively short code you should
be able to see here that I something
that looks like V tilde dist and I have
to say okay in that assignment is that
thing a parameter if V is a parameter
then I'm going to replace this with a
par and if it's not a parameter I'm
going to replace it with data so based
on whether it's a parameter or not I
know which of those two arguments it
came from then the entire the entire
body the green box over here is just
this whole thing where we say okay I've
got whatever assignment I set up and
then I increment the log posterior
density and then this this quote at the
bottom is the full form of the of the
function that we return something that
comes up a lot in Bayesian analysis is
to be able to determine the dependency
graph for a given model so this is
important in factor graph models or if
you're doing something like a
variational approximation you need to
look at the second second derivative
matrix that the hessian and it turns out
that the the graph structure will inform
us of the sparsity structure for the
hessian so this is something that can be
very useful and this is only we can get
to pretty quickly in sauce this is a a
model specifying the latent dirichlet
allocation model for text analysis and
this is the this is the graph that comes
from the original fly paper and if I
just say dependencies of Lda we get the
graph
okay so future work I'd like to be able
to represent more types of models in
particular I think it's really important
to be able to represent online models
like home and filtering and I think as
you go across different probabilistic
programming languages there are
different kind of models that they're
able to reason about so for example we
have Universal when they call universal
probabilistic programming languages like
touring that can represent anything in
terms of a simulation and then we have
modeling approaches with more
constraints that in exchange get more
more powerful algorithms in a sense
things like Stan so if we had a
particular if we had a model model
higher type hierarchy then for a
particular type of model we could reason
about what kind of imprint procedures
would apply to that type of course more
backends it's of course totally feasible
to connect sauce with existing
probabilistic programming languages and
that's something that that I very much
have in mind and would like to do of
course variational inference is huge
these days if you don't work in Bayesian
analysis and it might not be something
you've heard much about but if you do
anything Bayesian it's it's kind of all
the rage these days for doing things
with big data in particular there's a
DVI
auto automatic differentiation
variational inference and then there's a
V I mentioned the uber labs uber AI labs
pyro system so that style of variational
inference I think has a huge potential
finally more modeling combinators there
there is a transformation that people
make a lot by hand called the non
centric parameterization this has a lot
of benefits in terms of the the the
dependence of the parameters so we can
we can encode this as a model
transformation things like
distributional approximation or what I'm
calling pre Gibbs decompositions if I
have a model then
for Gibbs for Gibbs sampling I would
like to look at the conditional
probabilities where only one parameter
at a time is unobserved or we can do
something like a block Gibbs
decomposition the the organizers for
julia khan 2019 have asked me to to
mention that julia Khan is coming up
July 21st to 27th is going to be in
Baltimore Maryland and that's all I have
thank you
[Applause]
Thank You Chad any questions I've got my
back already guys so the not well so
there's there's some very limited
material on my well in the sauce and the
sauce github repository I'm planning to
and probably 10 or 11 weeks start to go
back into this kind of full force and
spend a lot of my spring working on this
in the meantime hopefully a little bit
more documentation maybe a blog post
here and there and then I hope to really
move it forward more quickly in the
spring yeah yeah it'd be great more
questions
alright thanks again Chet thank you
[Applause]
you